(crowd applauding)
- Hello.
- I'm so sorry.
We couldn't find a daytime
friendly clip for you to play
A movie.
- I just love it.
The whole clip was like burp! Burp!
I love it. That the
show it seemed so funny.
Do you love it?
- Thank you.
- Do you love doing it?
I'm yeah, no,
I love it.
It's huge.
It's based on pride and prejudice.
So it's actually, oh
(group chatters excitedly)
- Yeah. So insane.
- It really is.
And I have to say
like really quickly to them too.
Like I grew up watching
The Pride and Prejudice BBC mini series of
- Oh, Colin Firth
- And Jennifer Neely.
Yes. Yeah.
- Like, so watching your show,
like I never thought growing up
that I would ever see myself
in Regents, England
ever in a million years.
So your show is really like
it's, I know we talked about
like kids seeing themselves represented.
- Yeah.
- But I'm like a 34 year old man.
And it like it means a lot.
- Aw.
- No, that's so cool.
- Yeah.
- It is like so cool.
That it's so different
- Yeah. That's why I wrote the movie.
I was like, I'm never gonna
be in Pride and Prejudice,
so I I have to do it myself.
- I love that.
- Yeah.
- That's my favorite
Pride and Prejudice too
- Yeah. I hear, I hear.
- Colin Firth, hey yeah.
(everybody laughing)
- So a lots changed in your
life since you were last here.
So what's been happening
- A lot.
I mean, I'm in love since the last time.
- I love that
(audience cheering)
- It's pretty big deal.
I bought, I'm a first time home homeowner.
- Oh that's big.
- Yeah.
- You're like a, you're like adulting.
- I know.
It's crazy.
It's all happened.
Yeah. I decided I came out of the pandemic
and I was like
it's time to be 34 years old.
And so that's what I did.
And I actually, yeah
my house is like
right around the corner from here
- Oh, mine is too.
- Yeah. We can hang out.
- Yeah I was like, I'm literally,
you can listen to one song.
- Okay.
- Because the traffic here sucks.
So I was like, I gotta live right by work.
So wait, so your new movie
it's called Fire Island.
So for those who don't know what makes the
the real Fire Island so significant?
- Well, the real Fire Island,
it is like a strip of
of land off of Long Island.
And
- I was just
- Talking about this with
literally with Corey.
Okay. Keep going. Okay.
- And there's a lot of
different parts of Fire Island
but there are two parts,
specifically Cherry Grove and the Pines
that are all gay.
- Yeah.
- And they're like a gay
sort of enclave there.
And since like truly the 1940s,
like gay people
have been flocking to those areas.
And especially like,
especially like in the
sixties and the fifties
when it was basically illegal
for us to congregate,
like that was a safe haven.
- Yeah.
- And so it's like
has a lot of historical significance
and now it's, you know, it's a vacation
destination for gay men.
- Yeah.
- And women and people
of all queer identities
and stuff like that.
But it is like, it's really special
because I don't know.
I don't think a lot of
people realize sort of
the weight that queer
people will carry around
navigating a straight
society day in and day out.
And I love you guys,
but it is nice to go for a week where
there are no straight
people and it's freeing.
It's freeing.
It's really transformative
- Yeah.
to be able to experience that.
Okay. So you wrote this movie, right?
- I did. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay.
- Wow.
- And like I said
it's loosely based off
of Pride and Prejudice.
It's sort of the same way
Clueless is based off of Emma.
- Yeah.
- We did that for Pride and Prejudice. So
- I wrote it myself.
- Yeah. But that's the cool thing is
that you are a part of Hollywood,
you know what I'm saying?
So you can do that.
That's what I think is, is amazing.
That's the same thing with
like Sean Rams doing that.
Like, I think it's amazing.
You make what you want to have.
That's what I think.
- Cause I think people like you like
are like, I'm gonna break
down the barrier myself.
You've actually broken it down for
all the other people
coming behind you as well.
So it's gonna mean so much
to people to go, oh, if he did it,
maybe I can do it. You know?
- Yeah. That's the hope too.
Like if you don't like the movie
or you don't feel represented
by the movie either
like I hope that that's what happens.
So people will just make,
keep making their own stories.
- Okay. Let's do a quick commercial break.
Joel's new movie is on Hulu June 3rd
and it's called Fire Island
and his Netflix comedy special
is called Psychosexual.
It starts streaming June 21.